all right great to have you all here
thanks for being here I want to tell you
about something really cool that's
developing and as we speak and then some
other things as well we got to talk
about the show today but before we do it
before we get to the topic at hand the
topics at hand here's an alarming
statistic for you okay over 75% of
Americans are dangerously deficient in
omega-3 levels if you're experiencing
joint pain chronic inflammation lack of
concentration weight gain chances are
you're probably one of them so no matter
your age your height your weight your
gender omega-3 fatty acids are vital to
your overall health and considered a
miracle pill by experts and they're
clinically proven to improve your mood
your memory your brain cardiovascular
health all of that but problem is many
of the top sellers do not contain enough
omega-3 omega-3s to to bring about
noticeable therapeutic results if you
want to feel the benefits instantly then
you need to try Oh max three ultra-pure
that's the only game-changing omega-3
supplement on the market 94% pure o max
3 is clinically tested certified
sustainably sourced so that means it's a
hundred percent safe for you and your
family here's the here's the important
point Oh max 3 is offering my listeners
50% off of a one month supply of Oh max
three plus free shipping and then
there's also a 60-day money-back
guarantee so you got the free shipping
50% off money-back guarantee and you
can't beat that just go - Oh max
health.com enter a code Walsh today to
take advantage of this deal
that's om ax health calm and enter code
Walsh for 50% off of a one-month supply
well you hear all the hype around Omega
Omega 3s now is your chance to try the
most trusted omega-3 in the market today
just go - Oh max health calm and enter
code Walsh all right let's begin the
show with good news for a change well
first I guess I have to back up and set
it up with the bad part so I I already
lied
we'll start with we'll start with the
bad part and then we'll transition to
the good part
you may remember yesterday on the show
we discussed this guy Brian Simms who
is a democratic state representative in
Pennsylvania he is far far left
identifies himself as in his Twitter bio
as an LGBTQ activist and also a RuPaul's
Drag Race fanatic as well as a Little
Mermaid enthusiast which is totally
normal for a grown man right to be a
little mermaid enthusiast well brian
normal brian hates pro-lifers i mean he
really really hates them and he enjoys
therefore hanging out outside of his
local Planned Parenthood there in
Philadelphia and harassing peaceful
pro-lifers especially old ladies and
children who are by the way his
constituents these are the people that
he's supposed to be representing but
instead of representing them he bullies
them you know not exactly the same thing
so just to refresh your memory here's
the clip I played yesterday on the show
this is him harassing and bullying an
elderly woman and keep in mind that this
video goes on for eight minutes I'm
gonna play just a piece of it but this
is eight minutes of this watch this hi
everyone
representative Brian Sims here and I'm
once again out in front of Planned
Parenthood of southeastern Pennsylvania
it's not only in my district it's the
most heavily protested Planned
Parenthood I believe in the country and
today's protester now she is an old lady
who's gonna try to avoid showing you her
face but the same laws and luckily that
protect her from being out here also
protect me from showing you who she is
and so my hope is is that you'll donate
a hundred dollars for every extra hour
that this woman is out here telling
people what's right for their bodies
let's have a couple questions for you
ma'am how many children have you clothed
today
I'm sorry I missed your answer how many
children have you closed today
how about how many children have you put
shoes on their feet today have you fed
any children today or have you just
stood out in front of a Planned
Parenthood shaming people for something
that they have a constitutional right to
do you can pray at home for children
it's probably the same place you could
feed a child but you're not instead
you're out here shaming people for
something that they have a
constitutional right to do who'd have
thought that an old white lady would be
out in front of a Planned Parenthood
telling people what's right for their
bodies shame on you shame on you for
hiding your face at the same time that
you're shaming other people again the
same laws that protect me protect you
and and that's okay you're allowed to be
here that doesn't mean that you have a
moral right to be out here shame on you
what you're doing here is disgusting
this is wrong you have no business being
out here yep disgusting but but Brian
he's not a coward who just focuses on
the elderly no he's a coward who likes
to target children also so watch this hi
everyone representative Brian Sims here
and I am outside the Planned Parenthood
at southeastern Pennsylvania
oh no they're leaving now oh we've got
here a bunch of protesters a bunch of
pseudo Christian protesters who've been
out here shaming young girls for being
here and to give us a deal I've got $100
to anybody who will identify any of
these three look about what you're doing
nothing Christian about what you're
doing nothing Christian or loving or God
about what you're doing so I've got $100
to anybody who'll identifies $100 see if
you got some friends out here
a hundred bucks it'd be easier if you
just give me your name your address way
from rich what makes you think that it's
your job to tell women what's right for
their body and the truth is I'm not
really asking because I don't care shame
on you
plant paradise is attacks daily from
people like this from pseudo Christians
saying that they are here to somehow
protect or their own version of
Christianity so do me a favor if you've
watched this please consider giving $100
to Planned Parenthood I'm gonna do the
same there he's not only harassing and
bullying those kids but he's also trying
to Docs them he's trying to basically
put a bounty out to get their addresses
now why does this man want these kids
addresses I don't know I mean we can
only speculate it's a it's a very along
with being bullying and despicable it's
a very strange thing here's the thing
though I talked about this on the show
yesterday and I was heated I was angry I
still AM
when I see peaceful pro-lifers treated
that way it just it pisses me off
frankly and when the peaceful pro-lifers
happen to be kids or elderly women who
are being targeted well that's gonna
really send me through the roof but I
don't want to be just angry and complain
nothing wrong with complaining I do it
all the time it's one of my favorite
pastimes it's it's it's what I do for a
living but I don't want to do more than
that I don't want to just complain so
yesterday I you know I had the thought I
put it out there on Twitter I said let's
get a huge rally together and actually
show up physically to this place this
Planned Parenthood in Philly and to this
place where you know where these people
are being harassed and shows some some
solidarity with those who are being
bullied and also most importantly to
stand for the babies and also to show
Brian Sims that we aren't going to sit
back and let you treat elderly
and and kids that way let's give Brian a
chance to man up and try pulling those
stunts when there's a whole bunch of us
out there including other grown men that
was a suggestion that I made on Twitter
and within hours it came together it
came into fruition now it's really going
to happen
I spoke with Lila Rose over at
live-action I talked to Abby Johnson I
heard from a bunch of other pro-life
groups heard from other conservatives
and the movement like graham allen he's
he's gonna be there so it's happening
11:00 a.m. on Friday at the Planned
Parenthood in Philadelphia where these
pro lifers have been harassed that's
1144 Locust Street
11:44 Locust Street in Philadelphia I'm
gonna be there you know I so let's let's
do it it's I'm hoping for a big crowd
I'm expecting one this this thing has
blown up just in the last few hours like
I said it was late last night that I had
this thought put it out there and it's
already you know people are buying plane
tickets to show up to this thing so if
you can come out I know it's a workday
and and if you can't get off work then
you can't but it is something worth
taking off time for if you can if it's
possible but I would ask you to come out
come out and stand for life for the
babies and stand against bullying
because Pro lifers are treated this way
far too often this is very common this
happens all the time I mean I play
videos like this on the show a lot
you've seen this kind of stuff on the
show and other and elsewhere online
because this is common don't think for a
minute that Brian Sims is the only jerk
in America who likes to harass a
peaceful elderly pro-life protesters and
no is this especially you know that the
woman in the video who by the way is
just courageous and filled with grace
and patience far more than than I have
far more of all three of those things
grace patience and courage than I have
but I think I'm guessing one of the
reasons why she was able to respond so
calmly to those provocations is that you
know she's an older woman in in the
pro-life movement
she's probably been doing this a long
time and if she has that is certainly
not the first time she's been treated
that way
III am guessing that she's been treated
that way many times as any pro-lifer
who's been in it for a long time has
been so this is not about when we all go
there on Friday this is not just about
Brian Sims this is about making a
statement about all that you know
against all of the abuse
that's heaped and not just on pro lifers
either but on but on people who are
exercising their First Amendment rights
and who suffer abuse and and ridicule
and intimidation
because of it so this is a this is a
this is a pro First Amendment thing and
it's also pro-life it's both of those
things and I think it's gonna be great
I'm just I'm thrilled that this came
together the way that it did and I think
we should do this more often
right when we see something like this
and we're all talking about it online
and it's going viral and we're we're all
upset about something well let's do
something let's actually go places and
do things and show up and not just be
online so again that's Friday 11:00 a.m.
11:44 Locust Street the Planned
Parenthood in Philadelphia I hope to see
you there all right Cory Booker is
drowning in the polls and trying to save
himself now by out liberal in his
opponents and he just unveiled a massive
anti second amendment plan which I will
allow an article New York Times to
describe almost like a so this is what
the New York Times says about Booker's
plans those aspects of mr. Booker's
fourteen part plan are among the most
progressive gun control measures
suggested by candidates seeking the
Democratic nomination for president and
are likely to face sharp criticism from
gun rights advocates like the National
Rifle Association mr. Booker said in a
statement my plan to address gun
violence is simple we will make it
harder for people who should not have a
gun to get one I'm sick and tired of
having of hearing thoughts and prayers
to the communities that have been
shattered by gun violence
while you have to make a false choice
there between thoughts and prayers and
this but the most notable piece of mr.
Booker's plan is the proposed gun
licensing program which would enact
minimum standards for gun ownership
nationwide under such a program a person
seeking to buy a gun we need to apply
for a license in much the same way that
one applies for Passport mr. Booker's
campaigns that the process would involve
submitting fingerprints and sitting for
an interview and would require
applicants to complete a certified gun
safety course each applicant would also
undergo a federal background check
before being issued a gun license which
would be valid for up to five years so
you have to go and do this every five
years we are interviewed you get
fingerprints well I assume the
fingerprints they would only do the one
time you you think a gun safety course I
don't know if you do that every five
years other parts of the plan would
include banning bumped stocks which
enables semi-automatic weapons to fire
faster limiting bulk purchases of
firearms closing loopholes that allow
domestic abusers and people on terror
watchlist to obtain guns and the plan
calls for the IRS to investigate the NRA
raise tax exempt status so we're lumping
that into this is just a goodie bag of a
grab bag of far-left initiatives Booker
also said if you need a license to drive
a car you should need a license to own a
gun and that's kind of how he summarizes
his plan here now the plan also involves
gun confiscation which is something that
Democrats always say they aren't
interested in doing but before we get to
that part of it as for this idea of
everyone having to get a federal license
to own a gun there are two things number
one if you need a license to drive a car
you should need one to own a gun that is
a total non sequitur okay that's the
kind of thing that makes sense to you if
you're not really thinking about it it's
similar to the no-fly no-buy idea which
it sounds like is included in Booker's
plan where well if you're not allowed to
fly on a plane then you shouldn't be
allowed to own a gun
as if those two things are somehow
connected which they aren't just because
you need a license for one thing doesn't
mean you should need a license for some
other random thing that you can point
out why well for one gun ownership is a
constitutional right driving a car is
not and that's why the government can be
much more restrictive with the latter
because it's not a right it's not a
fundamental constitutional right whereas
owning a gun is also most vehicle owners
drive their cars every day they put
hundreds of thousands of miles on a car
then they trade it in they've been they
buy a new one and they put hundreds of
thousands of miles on that car
the average American drives over
thirteen thousand miles a year so if you
add up if your figure they start driving
when they're sixteen seventeen and and
if you look at all their drive here
that's probably like 700 or 800 thousand
miles and a life coming they drive
meanwhile the average gun owner never
uses or rarely uses the gun at all
that's the average gun owner
the average gun owner has the gun in a
safe or in a closet or something and
they rarely if ever there ever pull it
out it's not an everyday item for most
people now it is an everyday item for
some people and as for the gun owners
who use the thing much more often and
who you know that who have a lot of guns
and they go target shooting or they hunt
or whatever well
the issue becomes self regulating for
them because they those people are
already they learn about guns they
become experts they do that on their own
so find me any random person on the
street who owns 20 guns and uses them
regularly and I guarantee that person is
very knowledgeable and very adept at
using firearms safely there is this
obviously the impression of the the gun
owner that Democrats want you to have is
that these are people who are unhinged
and dangerous and so on but that's just
not the case
I know a lot of people I'm a gun owner
myself but I know a lot of people who
are who are you know gun enthusiasts and
they have a lot of guns and every single
one of them it's they're extremely
knowledgeable they are they not only
know how to use a gun safely but they're
obsessive about using a gun safely and
if they if they see a picture online of
someone you know holding the gun in it
you know improperly you're doing
something on say they're gonna you know
freak out so it's not just that they use
guns safely if they are they are just
extremely you know obsessive about it
and that's the that's and that's how it
is so this is a self regulating thing
this idea that you need a driver's
license type of license it just becomes
redundant the whole point here is that
the point of a driver's license is not
to make it so that the government can
keep track of you at least that's not
the stated point of the driver's license
now that might really be the point at
the end of the day but ostensibly the
point is that you need to learn how to
drive safely before you actually get
behind the wheel so you don't kill
someone well as I said that's not an
issue with guns most people never use
them anyway and those who do already
know how to use them safely and it's not
an issue as for those people who use
them regularly and aren't interested in
safety let's say like gang members I
mean think about the kinds of people who
might own a lot of guns use them a lot
yet they don't care about safety and
they are they use the guns in dangerous
ways well that is a category people
exclusively populated by criminals and
gang members and drug dealers like
that's that's what you're talking about
there and those people they're not gonna
bother getting a license you can pass
all the licensing laws you want but they
don't care everything that everything
they do what their life is illegal
they're committing crimes all the time
they don't care about that and in fact
if you're someone who you know you're
gonna use your gun
to commit crimes because you're a
gangbanger let's say well you're not
gonna go and get a license for it
anymore anymore than you would you know
call up the police and ask them if it's
okay if you go shoot up the the you know
do a drive-by shooting like you're not
going to do that you you know that it's
illegal and you're doing it anyway so
then you have the only people who are
going to obey a licensing law are
precisely the people who don't who we
don't need to have licensed because for
them it's redundant they're already safe
gun owners and the second point which is
related to this is how exactly I mean
walk me through the steps here so step
one is federal licensing law everyone
has to get sliced license if you own a
gun and then there's like some sort of
in-between step and then the third step
is fewer mass shootings well what is the
in but what happens in between I
understand your idea here is you know
you do this and then that's the result
but but I don't see how you have you
bridge that gap because it seems to me
as I said the people who know that they
want to use guns to commit crimes are
not gonna bother getting licensed so
that's out and anyone who is a you know
a responsible and safe gun owner and
then let's say they go crazy one day and
they decide they want to go shoot up a
you know a shopping mall or something
well the license isn't going to stop
them from doing that because the point
is at the time when they went to get the
license they didn't have that in mind
they were responsible you know
law-abiding citizens so there would be
no basis upon which to not give them the
the license what's gonna stop them after
they get the license what what about
that license would prevent them from
having a psychotic break down and then
going and killing people that's what I
don't see that's just come
pointless but the other aspect of cory
booker's plan as I mentioned is gun
confiscation which the Democrats have
always told us they're not interested in
that and they still even though you have
now a Democrat presidential candidate
proposing gun confiscation he still
won't admit that's what he's doing
even though it's clear that's what he's
doing watch this before you go just one
final question on your gun proposal
since you've just released it this
morning your fellow your competitor in
the 2020 race congressman Eric swallow
has also like you proposed in a assault
weapons ban but he's proposing a buyback
program where Americans who currently
have those guns could sell them
essentially to the government but if
they don't within a certain period of
time they would be prosecuted so subject
can be thrown in jail perhaps are you
supportive of the same measure well
first of all when I was mayor of the
City of Newark again I have a record on
dealing with gun violence we did a lot
of gun buybacks and even other creative
ideas that I think we should have when
I'm president United States the critical
thing is I think most Americans agree
that these weapons of war should not be
on our streets yes what do you would you
prosecute people do you support the
government buying them back and if not
potentially people could go to jail if
they don't want to sell them back yes or
no again we should have a law that bans
these weapons and we should have a
reasonable period in which people can
turn in these weapons right now we have
a nation that allows in streets and
communities like mine these weapons that
should not exist okay so he doesn't he
doesn't want the the soundbite of him
actually saying yes we're going to
prosecute people who don't voluntarily
turn in their guns but that's what it is
voluntarily turning your guns in a
buyback program and but if you don't
voluntarily do it then we'll put you in
prison that's obviously the implication
here because this is a mandatory thing
you have to turn in your assault you're
a quote unquote assault well I'm using
the hand quotes way to mature you have
to turn in your quote unquote assault
weapons and which you know we need to
figure out what the hell that even is
what what is an assault
and no one knows what that word even
means what that phrase it means it
doesn't really mean anything but it
turned those in and you have a grace
period upon you know in which you can
you can do that and but if you don't do
it then there's obviously going to be
some kind of penalty so this is forced
gun confiscation being proposed by Cory
Booker and there's just there's just no
way around that conclusion it's very
clear alright um finally before we get
to emails I've got to talk to you about
something yeah I've this is really
important we need to talk about we need
to spend a couple minutes on this
yesterday I was I was out and it was it
was lunchtime and I was thinking you
know I'm hungry I gotta get something to
eat so I was thinking maybe I go to
McDonald's or Taco Bell or Arby's which
are all wonderful places beautiful
places that have just great high quality
food but I thought you know what I want
to eat healthy I'm gonna be healthy yes
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be healthy
for a change
and I'm gonna really make a healthy
choice and mainly I was thinking that
way because I had just come from getting
fitted for a tuxedo for my friend's
wedding and and in the process of
getting fitted for the tuxedo of course
they have to take your waist measurement
and my waist measurement was let's say a
bit more generous than I would have
preferred and also I was shamed because
as you know I'm in the this kind of busy
tuxedo place and the guys taking the
measurements and for some reason like
he's just taking the measurements so
that he can write them down on a piece
of paper but for some reason he
announces the measurements out loud like
lactic Elise creams them into a bullhorn
he does the waist measurement as though
the waist is then he shouts it to
everybody around him for some reason so
I was feeling shamed depressed obese and
and so I said I'll do something healthy
and there was this vegan health food
smoothie place like this one of those
smoothie and juice places trendy little
places nearby the type of place that
puts kale
carrots into their smoothies the type of
place that makes that makes the kind of
food that zookeepers would give to like
baby pandas and so I said I'm gonna go
and I went in and I got a smoothie and
this is what the smoothie looked like oh
look at this that that's not a it's not
a joke I didn't this that you know it's
not camera tricks that's really what
they serve me okay looks like it looks
like the Jolly Green Giant went on a
tequila bender and then was hungover and
puked into a cup that's that's what that
looks at it looks like it looks like
regurgitation and it tasted like despair
it was I I when I tasted it I felt this
sudden sensation of total misery like I
can't even describe it I was already
depressed about the waistline thing and
then I tasted this thing and I I could
barely I almost cried I almost wept
that's how bad bad it was but this is
what vegans eat and this is why vegans
are dangerous people
they are vegans are essentially drinking
the contents of a rabbits intestines and
this is what they live what these people
are sick they're psychos this is this is
this is a really disturbing and if this
is what eating healthy means and I have
no interest I I retire from healthy
eating
III experimented with healthy eating for
one meal in my 32 years of life and I'm
done with it now in fairness that
smoothie the name of that smoothie on
the menu was called
immunization station immunization in
immunization station was the name of the
of the item on the menu there was a
slightly better looking smoothie that at
least didn't have carrots in it but the
name of that smoothie on the menu was
fab and fruity fab and fruity was the
name of the thing and there and I wanted
that's when we but there was just no way
I was gonna order something that
required me to say yes I'll have the fab
and fruity please thank you I just I
couldn't do that
I couldn't and and I run into that a lot
at places where
then the menu item I want has a really
embarrassing and humiliating name and I
can't bring myself to say it
so I take something I don't want and so
I went with this and it killed me it
really I died I died and I came back to
life and I wished I was still dead
that's how bad it was and so I threw
them this monstrosity away and I went to
Arby's because if this is what it takes
to live to 90 then I'll take the French
fries in the early exit thank you very
much and I will enjoy my abbreviated
life which will be filled with grease
and fries and hamburgers like an
American like a human not a vegan all
right let's get those some emails Matt
wall show at gmail.com Matt well showed
you my like um this is from Caitlyn says
greetings a wise and bearded supreme
leader leader of the multiverse of the
oh yeah the mall so I'm the leader of
the month not just the universal
multi-verse very good good point thank
you for the insights and advice that you
share in your podcast it's often one of
the highlights of my day I wanted to ask
you if you get nervous or ever get or
ever got nervous before doing a podcast
or a speaking event I used to be a very
confident public speaker however I have
recently started to feel nervousness at
the beginning of my speeches and
presentations I settled back down after
a few minutes but I do not know how to
handle myself when my voice shakes it
gets quiet what do you do if when you
get nervous and I generally don't get
nervous
before I definitely don't get nervous
before something like a podcast which is
just me talking to myself basically most
time I even forget that anyone else is
going to listen to this this for
speeches no I don't get nervous before
Smith the only thing I get nervous about
before a speech is the turnout I want to
I I want there to be a good turnout if
there's a good turnout then I'm not then
I'm good to go I'm not gonna be nervous
I'm a lot more uncomfortable making
small talk individually with people than
giving speeches I would rather give a
speech to a thousand people than make
small talk with one person that's that's
just how I'm wired and by the way most
people speak publicly most public
speakers are that way as for ways to
cure nervousness well don't imagine the
audience naked I don't know where that
nugget of wisdom came from you know
people say imagine the audience naked it
will cure stage fright it that
definitely does not it's it's just it'll
it'll it's disturbing and it's confusing
and so I would not try that tactic what
I would say for any kind of social
anxiety is this keep in mind how little
everyone actually cares about you and
and your performance I don't mean that
as a as an insult it's the same for me
it's the same for everybody
it may sound discouraging but it really
isn't it's actually liberating because
when you're sitting there and you're
going oh no or but people are people
judging me are they enjoying what I'm
saying or they are what are they
thinking about me well just realize that
they're probably not thinking about you
at all and even if you're up there
giving a speech and you bomb and you
just give a terrible speech of the worst
speech anyone has ever heard within five
minutes of that speech ending everyone
will have already moved on with their
life and they won't be thinking about it
and they probably will never think about
it again within five minutes they're
they're back to thinking about oh what
are we gonna get to eat oh I got a you
know we're having car problems I gotta
take this car to the shop you know
whatever I mean just they're thinking
about a million other things in their
own life they're not thinking about your
speech I've had a few speeches that
didn't go over well and well I've had
I've had many speeches that didn't go
over well but but it meant many cases
the speech didn't go over well but I
still feel like it was a great speech
and so I don't care about that I have
had speeches that didn't go over well
and when I look back I think well that
wasn't a great speech I wish I had
written it differently I'd wish I'd made
this or that change and sometimes I
think back on them and I and I think man
I wish I had you know I start thinking
about changes I wish I had made but then
I realized that literally no one else in
the universe is thinking about that
speech or the mistakes that I made no
one else I am the only part of all the
beings in the universe I am the only one
who is thinking about that no one
everyone else has moved it most people
never knew about it
and the few that did have moved on long
ago then they don't even remember it so
relax is what I'm saying it doesn't it
doesn't really matter that much you know
and with a speech I here's thing most
speeches that people give are just
unremarkable and kind of boring that's
the vast majority of speeches that have
been delivered in the history of speech
giving have been unremarkable and boring
and you know it's just what speeches are
most of the time and so people just
forget about them and then that's all it
does Matt it's not humiliating for you
it's just you know it's just most people
they go okay it was a speech you gave a
speech whatever you know kind of boring
but fine if if you're really the only
time you can really make an impression
on someone so that they'll remember it
is if you deliver a great speech now you
could make an impression by delivering a
great speech and so if you do that great
but bombing when you're giving a speech
mostly just means it was kind of boring
and unremarkable and people are gonna
forget about that so I guess what I'm
saying is you're kind of playing with
house money you got nothing to lose
either either you won't give a good
speech and people will forget about it
fine whatever or you give a great speech
and people remember it and and they do
remember that and it does have some
impact on them and that's good too so
you know you don't don't have a lot to
use the only the only thing to worry
about in public speaking is that you
like pee your pants or something while
you get like if something like that now
that your life is basically over in that
case let's be honest if people will
remember that for as long as they live
and talk about it so just don't do that
and or vomit or something no bodily
fluids should make it appearance aside
from that you're fine all right let's go
to we'll do
this is from don't have the names as hi
Matt I'd like to ask a question about
different styles of music offered in
church I prefer singing traditional
hymns as I think their language more
properly expresses theological concepts
other people however argue that choice
of music and church is purely a personal
preference and whatever style gets
people in the door and singing along as
acceptable do you have a stance on this
issue or any feeling towards music in
general in church generally yeah I've
talked about this before I do have a
stance on the issue I think that III
think that the traditional hymns it's
not just that they're traditional it's
that in most cases 95% of the time the
traditional hymn is just better like it
just it expresses not not only the
theological concepts but the emotion the
feeling of worship and a being before
the divine it expresses that in a much
more eloquent meaningful relatable
affecting way and so that's why I say
stick with traditional hymns is because
they are simply better almost always
there may be a few very few exceptions
of hymns that were written in the last
20 years that are just as good if not
better than traditional and I can't
think of any I don't think there have
been any that are better III but I'll
allow for the fact that I haven't heard
all of them so maybe there's a good one
out there somewhere but most of the time
they simply aren't as good and so why so
the question is if the if the
traditional hymn is clearly better why
would you sing the new one instead and
the answer is you sing the new one
because it's new and you think well it's
chronological snobbery is what CS Lewis
called it it must be better because it's
even though it's not better the fact
that it's new kind of makes it better
and so let's do the new one and people
will you know we can get the young
people will like it more because it's
new everyone will like it more will be
more relevant will be more hip will
attract more people because it's new and
that's just not the case
these timeless hymns are timeless for a
reason they everyone loves them they
they relate to young people old people
doesn't matter who
so I say stick with us thanks for the
question oh and thanks everybody for
watching and listening Godspeed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show president Trump ratchets up
trade talks with China we will examine
the case for tariffs and we'll see how
that turns out then Pete but a judge
goes after president Trump's marriage
because Pete but a judge is a big jerk
check it all out of Daly wire calm